[Müzik]
8 yaşında
Refika annesinin getirdiği blazen'in
filmindeki
Los Angeles mimariyi saate sanatı mimari
işleme düşüncesi ve bir sahne onu şu an
olduğu Refika'nın O haline getirmiştir
O sahne Android Racer karakterinin
anılarını aslında kendisinin değil
başkasına ait anıların olduğu anlatıl
o sahneyi izledikten sonra ömrünün
sonuna kadar kendisini bırakmayacak olan
bir makine başkasının önüne ne yapabilir
sorusu ile uğraşmıştır ve
cevaplayabilmek için birçok çalışmalarda
bulunmuştur
çalışmalarını anlatmadan önce sanatçının
kendisine Refika'nın Doğu sizlerle
tanıştırmak istiyorum
refikanadol 1985 İstanbul doğumlu bir
medya sanatçısı alanında Öncü olmakla
kalmamış sayısız sanatçı ve ilham
olmuştur
yaptığı çalışmalardan dolayı kazandım
birçok ödülü olmakla beraber yüksek
öğretim görmek için gittiği
yıllar uzamaya devam ediyorum
çok güzel özetlediğini düşünüyorum bir
söz var sizlerle bunu paylaşmak
istiyorum
ben vereyim pigment olarak kullanıp
Yapay Zeka tarafından desteklenmiş
düşünen bir fırçayla mimari hibayarak
binaların Hani istilasyon ve Riga
görmesini sağlıyor
kısıtlı süremiz olduğundan dolayı sadece
3 tanesinden bahsedebileceğim birincisi
de Arkan Premier
İlhan'ın forgolis bölgesinin yazmış
olduğu Babil Kütüphanesi adlı kısa
öyküsünden almışlar
hikayede yazar belirli karakter setinde
ve fonta sahip yazılmış ve yazılabilecek
tüm 410 sayfalık kitapları içinde
bulunacağım ve kütüphaneden bahseder bu
ilham verici görüntüsüyle beraber
grubuyla
büyük veri arşivlerinin fiziksel olarak
incelemenin yollarını aramışlar
Bu doğrultuda saltanaşma merkezinden
topladıkları bir milyon 700 bin belgeyi
bir makineyi taratarak uyumaya
bırakmışlar ve Rüya görmesine izin
vermişler sonuç muhteşem bir deneyimdi
deneyimin dairesel bir özellik içinde
etrafınız bir projektörler ve aynalarla
çevrili olarak giriyorsunuz merkezdeki
bilgisayarla etkileşime geçene kadar
bilgisayar size verici işlerken gördüğü
rüyayı
başına etkileşime geçtiğimizde de
isterseniz kullanılan bir milyon yiyecek
bir belgeyi isterseniz de makine
zekasını rüyasında tanıklık
edebiliyorsunuz
yüksek öğretim görmek için gittiği Los
angeles'ta gördüğü hiçbir binanın Kuz
enini aşamadığını söylüyor tek bir
tanesi hariç O da Mimar Frank
bir binadan
çok konserlerini burada veren Los
Angeles
oyunu kutlaması için Refika balığı 2018
yılında 188 göndermişler grubu ile
beraber Teklif için 2 soruyu sormaya
öğrenebilir mi hayal görebilir mi
bunun için Los
angeles'lerindeki 77 terabaytlık bir
belgeye toparlayıp makine zekasını
kullanarak Golden
yazmalar haline getirmişler Los
angeles'ın kamu sağladı gelecek kişi
çalışmayı gerçekleştirmek için de ilk
projektör kullanmışlar
ve blace
görsel ve işitsel malzemeye dönüştürme
vizyonu bir diğer parçası olan Menzil
Nuri ilhamını trajik bir olaydan
amcasına alzhe teşhisi konulması
ardından almışlar grubuyla beraber Neyi
ve nasıl hatırladığımızda değer vermenin
yollarını
bulmak bu yolculukta durakları ilk
kaliforniya'daki laboratuvarı olmuş
orada beyinsiz yerleri hatırlamak ve
Anadolu oluşturma gibi süreçlerini
incelemek için 32 farklı noktada Egg
verilerini toplamışlar
gördüğünüz gibi Refika yaptığı
çalışmaların detaylıca görsellerde
yazılarla
ve Anadolu'nun herhangi bir Sanat
eserinin giriş ve çıkış kapısı olan
müzel
Erde bir parçası
bu süreçte amcası hatırlama ve ana
oluşturma gibi yeteneklerini kaybetse de
ehe
amcasının kaybettiklerini bir övgü
olarak kalmaya devam ediyor
ne kadar ben sadece 3 saatten de
bahsedebilmiş de olsam ben sizin diğer
çalışma alanlarından gözetmenizi çok
isterim örnek olarak 100 milyondan fazla
New York fotoğrafını bir makine
incelettirip sonra görmediği görselleri
oluştur
masını niha
veya Karadeniz ve Marmara denizden
topladıkları rüzgar ve deniz hareketleri
gibi meteorolojik verilerden oluşturmuş
oldukları Bosphorus ve Black
benim size bu durumda vermek
Türkiye sanatta herhangi bir değişiyor
dönüşüyor ve bu değişimi desteklemekte
Bizim diğer milli görevlerimizin
arasında
Sonuçta Ulu önderimizin de dediği gibi
bir millet sanattan ve sanatkardan
mahrumsa tam bir hayata Malik olamaz
Böyle bir millet hayatı
bilir Sanatsız kalan bir milletin hayat
damarlarından biri kopmuş olur beni
dinlediğiniz için